Professor Charles
Bailyn: We've been talking
about the expansion of the
Universe and in answer--I want
to follow up on something I said
kind of in answer to a question
last time, which is that it
turns out that the expansion of
the Universe alone doesn't
require you to have a Big Bang.
There are other explanations,
or in particular,
one other class of explanation,
which is compatible with the
observation of the expanding
Universe, but doesn't exactly
lead to a Big Bang,
in the sense that we think of
it today.
And so, I want to talk about
these alternatives.
This is Frontiers and
Controversies as of 1950.
In 1920, you'll recall,
they were worried about whether
the spiral nebulae were island
galaxies of their own,
or not.
That was settled by Hubble's
observation.
In the 1950s,
it had become clear that it
really is true that the Universe
is expanding.
But there were two categories
of explanation that were being
put forward to explain that,
and deciding which is which was
the current big topic of the
day.
So, the Universe expands.
And what do we make of this
fact?
Well, one option is the Big
Bang, what we now call the Big
Bang, which, as I've mentioned,
implies that in the past,
everything was closer together.
It was denser,
and that creates other changes.
If things get denser,
they also get hotter,
you may remember from
chemistry.
So, this implies in the past
things were different from how
they are now.
They were denser,
hotter, and that in the future,
it'll go the other way.
Things will become sparser and
cooler.
And there may be other changes
associated with this.
There may be different kinds of
galaxies in the past from now
and different kinds of galaxies
now, as compared to the future,
and so forth.
But the Universe is a place
whose bulk properties can change
in time.
So, things change in time.
And the implication is that you
can extrapolate this back to an
initial singularity--that there
was a moment,
at some point in the past,
where all currently existing
space was piled up in a single
point.
The way I talked about this
last time was that the scale
factor was equal to zero,
and so, there is this
implication of an initial
singularity.
Now, the initial singularity is
not the kind of thing that can
be verified scientifically,
because all the physical laws
break down the same way they do
in the singularity inside a
black hole,
or in an event horizon,
or something like that.
But nevertheless,
that's the implication.
That's the extrapolation of
this set of ideas.
But, at least,
at the time,
that was not the only set of
ideas that could explain this
expansion.
There was an alternative,
which was described as the
"steady state."
I should say that both of these
names were given to these ideas
by people who supported the
"steady state."
Big Bang was--that phrase was
used as an insult by the "steady
state" people to make fun of the
ideas of the Big Bang,
which we now actually know to
be correct.
And that's why that particular
phrase is, in a way,
so misleading--that they were
deliberately trying to obscure
and insult some of the ideas in
the Big Bang.
From time to time,
astronomical organizations and
popular magazines run contests
to rename the great theory and
come up with some better name
that won't give you in your mind
the impression of an explosion
coming out from some central
point.
And people send in suggestions
and it never gets anywhere.
We're stuck with the Big Bang.
But it is good to remember that
it was named by its opponents,
who supported the "steady
state."
So, how would this work?
The central idea here is that
the Universe expands,
but then, new matter and energy
is created to fill in the voids,
as the Universe expands.
So, sure, all galaxies are
moving away from us.
But new galaxies are being
created where the old galaxies
used to be.
And the consequence of that is
that the past and the future
both have similar bulk
characteristics.
The density,
the overall density,
is the same.
And other characteristics are
the same, because as things move
further away,
you've simply replaced them
with other things like them.
And so, now,
you have to kind of invent some
way of creating matter and
energy.
But that's not nearly as bad as
creating a whole Universe,
which is what you have to do in
the case of the Big Bang.
So, in this case,
the past and the future are the
same.
It also implies that the
Universe is eternal in contrast
to the Big Bang,
where there is this initial
moment,
which one then instantly asks,
well, how did that happen and
what happened before it?
So, we get around that.
This is an eternal process.
And it's also infinite.
And so, we don't have to start
asking these awkward questions
about what's outside the
Universe.
And so, people found this,
in some ways,
much more satisfying.
And so, there were these two
quite different explanations of
the observed fact that the
Universe was expanding.
Now, the historians of science,
who have studied this
controversy, some of whom make
the claim that which side you
ended up on in the 1950s,
before there was a lot of
evidence either way,
this was kind of a
philosophical rather than a
scientific question at the
time--that which side you ended
up,
here, depended largely on your
religious beliefs or lack
thereof.
And they document this--a lot
of the work on the Big Bang and
a lot of the supporters of the
Big Bang were,
as I mentioned last time,
Catholics.
In one important case,
this guy Lemaitre,
who worked out all the
equations, was in fact a
Catholic priest,
also a physicist in his spare
time.
And this is a nice kind of
idea, because from that point of
view--because it gives you this
initial moment of creation,
which is--if you're a religious
person, it's relatively easy to
come up with a reason why that
might have happened.
On the other hand,
a lot of the scientists,
particularly in Britain,
where the "steady state" was
largely developed,
were of a kind of atheistic or
agnostic turn of mind,
and they didn't like this
initial singularity.
And they liked the idea of an
eternal infinite Universe,
as actually Einstein did,
too, because you didn't have to
have a creation event,
and you didn't have to invoke
the kinds of ideas that come
along with that.
And there's some dispute over
how much this really mattered to
people.
But what was clear is in the
1950s, this was not a question
for which there was scientific
evidence either way.
And so, what the scientific
evidence said was that the
Universe expanded.
And then, you could follow
either of these arrows.
Interestingly,
however, these two hypotheses
make quite different
predictions, which in the end,
turned out to be testable.
And, in particular,
what it predicted,
if the Big Bang makes this very
strong prediction that the past
is fundamentally
different-looking from the
present.
Now, over the course of a human
lifetime, this isn't going to
make a lot of difference.
The galaxies don't get that
much further away from us in
twenty or thirty years.
But one can actually look into
the past by looking at things
that are far away.
This is because the speed of
light is finite.
When we look at the Sun,
we don't see the Sun as it is
right now.
We see the Sun as it was eight
minutes ago, when the light
started to travel toward us,
because the Sun is eight light
minutes away.
If we look at Alpha Centauri,
the nearest star other than the
Sun, if Alpha Centauri blew up
or disappeared or something
right now,
we wouldn't know about it for
four years because it's four
light years away.
Similarly, if we look at a
galaxy that's 10 megaparsecs
away, a parsec is three light
years, so a megaparsec is three
million light years.
Some galaxy that's 10
megaparsecs away,
that's 30 million light years
away.
So, we're seeing it not as it
is, but as it was 30 million
years ago.
Now, it turns out that in the
course of cosmic time,
a few million years here or
there doesn't make any
difference to anybody.
But once you get into billions,
now you're talking cosmic time.
And so, if you look at things
that are billions of light years
away, that turns out to be a
substantial fraction of the age
of the Universe predicted by the
Big Bang.
We'll get back a little later
in this lecture to how you
determine what the age of the
Universe is supposed to be.
But if you go back a
substantial fraction of the age
of the Universe,
if you look back over distances
that great,
then you predict that you ought
to see things that look
different from the galaxies you
see today,
because the Universe at that
time was denser and hotter,
and the galaxies were younger
on average,
and you ought to be able to see
some kind of differences.
So, the past is different from
the present, and this is
observable through this concept
of the "lookback time."
Just the fact that the further
away something is,
the longer it's taken the light
to travel to you.
And so, you're actually seeing
things not as they are right
now, but as they are in the
past.
And so, you can imagine a great
research project where you sort
of look at nearby galaxies to
see how things are in the
current day.
Then, you look at really,
really distant ones,
some substantial fraction of
the age of the Universe ago,
and you ask yourself the
question, "Are those galaxies
the same as the galaxies that
exist today,
or are they,
in some sense,
different?"
So that's a testable prediction.
There's also a testable
prediction on this side,
which is that you ought to
actually be able to find these
places where the new matter and
energy is being created,
because that's a constant
ongoing process.
It has to be,
because it's got to fill in the
empty spaces left behind by the
expanding galaxies.
So, the prediction over here is
that there exist places of
matter and energy creation.
So, this is potentially
testable.
And in the 1960s,
evidence was actually found
that kind of decided this
question, which is why we now no
longer believe in the "steady
state."
And two things happened;
actually, there were a number
of things that happened.
But one of them was the
discovery of what were called
"quasars."
These are now known to be
accreting supermassive black
holes, but they didn't know
that, then.
So, this is in the 1960s.
That's what we think they are
now, but they didn't know it
then.
All they knew is that they had
discovered a great source of
huge amounts of energy.
And you'd think that this would
be a very good thing--some kind
of unknown energy source would
be just the thing for the
"steady state" people,
because that's what they needed.
They needed some kind of source
of mass energy creation,
and indeed, that was claimed
for a little while.
The main characteristic of
these things is that they have
very high redshifts,
which implies very large
distances, because velocity is
proportional to distance.
That's the Hubble Law.
Everybody agreed that the
Hubble Law was right.
So, these things were known to
be large distances away.
And so, if you're a "steady
state" person,
you say, well,
that's great.
If they're so far away,
they must be incredibly bright,
otherwise we wouldn't be able
to see them, and there's our
energy source that we require.
If you're a Big Bang person,
what you say is,
now we've finally found a bunch
of things that are really far
away and we can ask the
question,
"Are things that are that far
away the same as in the local
Universe, or are they
different?"
And what it turned out--one of
the very first things that was
discovered is that there were
many more quasars in the past
than there are now.
And so, whatever they are,
supermassive black holes or
whatever hypothesis you have for
these things,
it turns out,
they're dying out.
There were more of them in the
past then there are now.
They were brighter.
And so, here is an example of a
significant change in the
composition of the Universe,
which is the thing that's
predicted by the Big Bang.
And so, although initially,
it looked like quasars might be
helpful to the "steady state,"
as soon as they started to get
enough of them so you could do
these kinds of statistical
tests,
it became the first really
strong evidence that the
Universe was changing in time.
This was not the only thing
that was discovered in the
1960s.
Another thing is the so-called
cosmic microwave background,
and we'll talk much more about
that later on.
Right now, I just want to say
that what this is,
is it's radiation that was
created--that was generated when
the Universe was much denser
than it is now,
much hotter than it is now.
In fact, it comes from
radiation emitted by ionized
hydrogen.
So, this is when the whole
Universe was at 10,000 degrees
or so Kelvin--obviously much
hotter than the Universe is
right now, and much smoother.
All this hydrogen,
rather than being locked up in
individual stars or in--and
stars concentrated in individual
galaxies,
all this hydrogen was very
smoothly distributed around
space.
And so, this came from a
time--this radiation,
which you can easily detect
with radio telescopes and the
like,
comes from a time when then
Universe was much denser,
hotter, and smoother than it is
today--again,
in accordance with the
prediction of the Big Bang.
So, this provided very strong
support for the Big Bang.
And the discoverers of this
have got--there have been Nobel
prizes given out on a regular
basis for discoveries related to
the cosmic microwave background.
And as I say, we'll come back.
I'll talk about that at some
length later on.
Another thing that was
discovered is that the Universe
is pretty clearly,
mostly, 3/4 hydrogen and 1/4
helium.
Just about every cosmic object
you see, not the Earth,
but the Solar System as a
whole, has those proportions.
And all stars have these
proportions and all galaxies
consist of stars that have these
proportions.
And it turns out,
this could be explained by the
Big Bang.
When it was denser,
hotter, and smoother in the
early Universe,
it was hot enough for hydrogen
fusion--hydrogen fusion into
helium.
But it didn't last very long
because the Universe was
expanding and cooling,
and you need to have very high
temperatures in order to have
hydrogen fusion.
That's why it can only happen
in the center of the Sun,
or in an atomic bomb explosion,
or something like that.
And so, the Universe,
for about three minutes,
was hot enough for hydrogen to
fuse.
And if you ask yourself,
what fraction of the hydrogen
fused during the time the
Universe was hot enough for that
to occur,
the answer turns out to be,
about a quarter of it--in exact
agreement with the currently
observed fractions of hydrogen
and helium in the Universe.
So, this is in first three
minutes.
There's a famous popular book
from the 1980s called The
First Three Minutes,
which discusses this,
by Steven Weinberg.
In the first three minutes,
one quarter of hydrogen fuses
into helium, and afterwards,
no more, because it's too cool
for these reactions to occur.
So, that was another piece of
evidence that the Big Bang was
the right explanation and the
"steady state" was not.
Yes, question?
Student: Is it actually
three minutes or is that just
[Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Sorry.
Student: It is actually
three minutes?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
if you start from time zero,
when everything is put
together,
after three minutes the
Universe has cooled sufficiently
so that you can't have hydrogen
fusion, generally.
Then, no more nuclear reactions
occur until much,
much later, when stars formed.
And, we know how fast the
Universe is expanding because we
can measure the Hubble Constant
now.
And so, you know how long it
takes for the Universe to expand
to the point where the
temperature drops enough so that
there's no general hydrogen
fusion anymore.
And then, you do this little
calculation to how much fuses
during that time.
Other questions?
Okay.
More recently,
with the Hubble Space Telescope
and other big ground-based
telescopes,
we've discovered that you can
now see galaxies that are very
far away, that are as they were
a substantial fraction of the
age of the Universe ago.
And, by now,
it's clear that galaxies evolve
and that the statistical
demographics of galaxies--how
many there are,
how massive they are,
how big they are,
all those kinds of things--that
those statistics change
dramatically over the course of
the Universe--over the course of
the amount of lookback time that
we can currently observe.
So, galaxies evolve very
significantly.
So, everything points toward
the Big Bang and away from the
"steady state," much to the
surprise of a lot of the
scientists who felt,
possibly correctly,
given what was known in the
1950s, that the "steady state"
was a much more elegant
solution.
And so, let's see.
The fable here is the demise of
the "steady state."
And the moral,
well, there are various morals
to this, but let me be
provocative and say that,
sometimes science is
anti-atheistic,
not anti-religious.
Because it could have come out
the other way,
right?
It could have turned out that
this "steady state" was right.
And then, you wouldn't have had
this moment of creation and you
wouldn't--and Pope John Paul II
wouldn't have been so
enthusiastic about astrophysics.
In just the same way,
it might have turned out that
human beings are fundamentally
different from all other species
of animals.
And if that had been true,
the geneticists would have
discovered that instead of what
they did discover.
And so, there's a feeling,
particularly in current
political debates,
that scientists are somehow
intrinsically anti-religious,
and I think that isn't true.
It isn't one way or another.
It's just a way of finding
stuff out.
And sometimes,
as in this particular case,
you might find out that the
atheists, or whatever the
atheists had proposed,
is wrong.
And that's actually what
happened in this particular
case.
So, the demise of the "steady
state" is one of the big things
that happened in the latter half
of the twentieth century.
And so, now,
the scientific evidence is
very, very strongly in favor of
the Big Bang.
I should define what I mean,
I think, by the Big Bang
Theory, because,
as I said, this is a phrase
coined by its enemies.
And it's one of these phrases
like "black hole," which
actually doesn't have a
technical definition,
and you get into trouble by
people using it in different
ways.
And so, if what you mean by
this is that,
in the past,
the Universe was denser and
hotter,
and smoother--because it's
constantly forming new stars and
galaxies.
Everything is getting more
lumpy with time--and that you
can extrapolate this to an
initial singularity,
then, I think there's extremely
strong scientific evidence in
favor of this.
But you have to keep your eye
on this word "extrapolate,"
because sometimes the Big Bang
is used to describe this moment
of initial creation,
or whatever you want to call it.
This initial moment of infinite
density, and somehow everything
starting to expand.
You can't observe that.
That's one of these things that
you can't see now,
or with our current theories at
any point in the future.
And so, that's an extrapolation.
That's not an observation.
And that's a fundamentally
different thing.
So, if you use Big Bang to
indicate that particular moment,
then you can say that the
scientific evidence for that
actual moment isn't strong,
and indeed, couldn't even exist
within our current theories,
because all of physics breaks
down, there.
And so, what I mean when I say
that there's a lot of scientific
support for the Big Bang is,
there is support for this idea
that the Universe is changing in
time.
It was denser,
hotter, and smoother in the
past, and that if you
extrapolate this back,
there was an initial
singularity some number of years
ago.
And you can actually figure out
how many years ago that was,
which is what I'm about to do
next.
And so, this is now the kind of
currently accepted theory.
I should say,
there are a few remnant
holdouts from the "steady state"
type, who annoy the rest of us
by not giving in.
And there's actually been some
interesting controversy over the
years about,
you know, how much telescope
time do you give to people whose
proposal is to look for the
places where mass is created in
the "steady state" theory,
if nobody else believes that
theory anymore.
And, by now,
the answer is none,
but it took quite a while to
get to that point.
Okay.
Student: Do people ever
lie about what they're going to
observe?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Do people lie about
what they're going to observe?
Excellent--the graduate
students are amused.
No.
What happens is this.
You have to present--so,
you have to write these
proposals, because the
telescopes are over-subscribed.
And you have to come up with a
plausible thing that you're
going to do.
Now, it then varies how this is
actually done in operation.
In the space telescope,
for example,
what you have to do is,
then, you fill out what's
called a Phase II form,
which tells exactly where the
space telescope is supposed to
point and for how long.
And you submit that,
and they upload it and they do
it.
If you deviated drastically
from the target list you gave
them when they approved your
proposal, that'll get flagged
and they won't do it.
On the other hand,
on ground-based telescopes,
you kind of go to the
telescope, and still,
in many cases,
you operate it yourself.
And there's not a lot of
control over where you point the
thing.
The control then happens later.
One of the key components of a
proposal for telescope time is
what you did with the data you
got from the last amount of
telescope time they gave you.
And, you know,
you have to list all the
publications,
or if you haven't actually
gotten to publishing anything,
which is usually the case with
me recently, you have to show
little graphs or,
you know, describe the data and
what you're going to do with it
and so forth.
And one of the things--I sit on
these committees that make these
kinds of decisions.
And one of the things you look
for is if they haven't done
interesting work and,
kind of, done what they claimed
they would do the last time
round, their proposal goes down
to the bottom.
You're always looking for ways
to trash other people's
proposals, because you've got
seven times more--in the case of
the space telescope,
you've got seven times more
proposals than you can grant,
of which only a small handful
are not worth doing.
And so, any opportunity you
have to say, you know,
these guys are bozos--you
definitely take that
opportunity,
because otherwise you have way
too many good proposals left
over.
So, there's a kind of internal
control that isn't explicit on
this sort of thing.
And after a while,
you know, if people keep
getting up in public and saying,
you know, quasars are sources
of mass energy creation and
therefore support the "steady
state"--even if they're a great
big quasar expert,
you start to get a little bit
queasy about giving them large
amounts of telescope time that
might be more profitably used by
someone else.
This, then, gets interpreted by
the remnant "steady state"
supporters, or whoever the
minority idea might be,
of a hugely oppressive
scientific bureaucracy,
you know, not allowing the
maverick,
wonderful thinker to do their
own thing.
And that, sometimes,
is true, but not often.
Most of the time,
it's the sane people not
allowing the insane people to
use the telescopes,
and that's actually a much more
common thing.
And so, while it can be good
propaganda to say,
yeah, these oppressive,
elitist,
bureaucratic people--mafia who
run the scientific world are not
allowing my great idea to get
any opportunities to prove
itself.
Most of the time,
it turns out,
the establishment is right.
And so, there is this
interesting question about
allocation of resources.
It's not just telescope time,
more importantly,
even, money.
There's a big debate right now,
for example,
in the theoretical physics
community about string theory.
String theory is the hot theory
of everything.
And everybody is supposed to be
a string theorist,
in theoretical physics,
at the moment,
except for a few people who
point out that it hasn't
actually been all that
successful in explaining
anything.
In fact, it hasn't explained
anything, ever.
And therefore,
might one not want to consider
alternative theories?
And then, the string theorists
say, but, you know,
this is a really good idea.
We've got to continue to look
at it.
One day we'll get it right and
we'll figure out everything.
And so, there has now,
recently, been some popular
books that claim that string
theorists are oppressing
everybody else by not letting
other kinds of good ideas be
funded,
and by not letting smart young
people who are working on other
things--by not hiring them into
departments,
and so forth.
It's an interesting argument,
and ongoing,
in the string theory community.
It's, sort of--as I
said--they've been writing
popular books on both sides of
this,
so, it's kind of busted out
into--you're going to read about
this, now, in the New York
Review of Books,
and places like that.
And so, what you do about
minority ideas--ideas that are
not supported by the current
paradigm of a given scientific
subject is a very tricky one,
and a very interesting one,
and one that needs to be
reevaluated from time to time.
And, in fact,
cosmology may be approaching
such a moment,
where a genuinely new idea is
going to have to be required.
We're probably not quite there
yet, but we'll talk about
alternative cosmological
theories toward the end of the
course.
Sorry, I didn't mean to go off
on this, but it's on my mind,
because, as I said,
I serve on these committees,
so you have to think about
these things.
Actually, the space telescope
people did a very interesting
thing.
At one point they decided--I
don't think they ever actually
followed through on this--that
5%,
or some small amount of the
time--different scientific
resources sometimes have
this–that,
like, 5% of the time goes for
risky science.
Science that's really weird,
and probably won't work--but if
it works, it's incredibly
important because committees
tend to not to want to do that.
They tend to want to do the
things that they know are going
to produce some good result.
And so, sometimes,
the people who organize these
things force the committees to
have a little category of
special, weird projects.
And then, of course,
what happens?
Five years later,
they analyze,
you know, where did all the
good science come from?
And if it didn't come from the
weird projects,
which is almost certainly the
case--although not 100%
certainly the case,
but generally the case--then
they say, look we've wasted 5%
of our money,
telescope time,
whatever it is.
We're going to close down this
program.
And then, you kind of have to
start over again.
So, how weird is weird?
Difficult to say.
All right.
The expansion of the Universe.
We now believe,
for the reasons I outlined,
that this indicates a kind of
Big Bang idea,
which means we can extrapolate
back to the moment that it all
started, and we can calculate
how long it took.
Let me do a simpler
calculation, but exactly
analogous.
Supposing you're in a car.
You're in a car and you're
driving at a speed of 50 miles
per hour.
And you are 100 miles away from
your starting point.
How long have you been driving?
So, this, they taught you how
to solve in seventh grade.
If you are 100 miles away,
you take time is equal to
distance over velocity
[t=D/V].
So 100 miles.
You're going 50 miles an hour.
That means you must have been
going for two hours.
Not such a hard problem.
There's a hidden assumption
though--sorry?
Student: Speed is
constant?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Speed is constant,
yeah--provided that the speed
is constant.
Okay.
But let's make that assumption.
Let's assume that the Universe
is expanding at the same rate
all the time.
How long has it been going?
Well, take some galaxy,
any galaxy.
It turns out,
it doesn't matter which galaxy.
And say--so,
galaxy A is at distance
D.
It's moving at velocity
V, away from us.
You know, that's the whole idea.
So, how long has it been since
it was right on top of us?
Well, so, it's been going for a
time equal to D/V.
By exact analogy with the
distance, velocity,
time, questions that they ask
you about--you know,
cars driving to Cleveland,
and stuff.
So, it's been going for time,
T= D/V.
But now, in the case of
galaxies, there's this
interesting relationship--that
V = H/D.
So, D/V = 1/H.
Okay?
And that can be measured.
That's Hubble's Constant.
And so, the age of the Universe
is equal to 1 over the Hubble
Constant, provided that the
expansion has been at a constant
rate.
Let me remind you,
H has been measured.
It's 70 kilometers per second
per megaparsec.
That's kind of an interesting
unit.
You've got kilometers per
megaparsec.
Both of those are measures of
distance.
This is basically velocity over
distance, but velocity contains
a distance within it.
So, if you were to cancel those
two distance terms in some way,
you'd have that the units of
the Hubble Constant are 1 over
seconds.
So, the units of 1 over the
Hubble Constant are seconds.
It's a measure of time.
It's reciprocal time.
1/H is a measure of time.
What is that time?
It's the age of the Universe.
What do I mean by the age of
the Universe?
That's how long it has been
since all galaxies and all
objects in the Universe,
all points in the Universe,
were piled on top of one
another.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Let's see,
did I write it wrong?
V equals – yeah.
I wrote it wrong.
V = HD.
Thank you.
And so, now,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to divide both sides
by H.
by V, and then it comes
out right.
Sorry, thank you very much.
Stop me when I do that.
Right, because this is the
Hubble Law.
Okay.
So, how old is the Universe?
Well it's 1/70 kilometers per
second per megaparsec.
That actually is not a very
useful unit of time.
So, let's see if we can do
better.
H is equal to 70
kilometers per second per
megaparsec.
Now, we want to cancel the
kilometers per megaparsec.
So, what we want to multiply
this by is the number of
megaparsecs in 1 kilometer.
That's a very small number,
right?
It's some tiny fraction,
because a megaparsec is huge.
It's, you know,
three million light-years,
or something like that,
and a kilometer,
not so huge.
So, let's calculate this term.
That's going to be--1 kilometer
is 10^(3) meters.
One megaparsec--a mega is
10^(6), so parsec is 3 x 10^(16)
meters.
And so, this is equal to 1/3
times--10^(-22)--10^(-19) equals
3 x 10^(-20),
right?
But it's 70 of those.
So, H is equal to 7 x
10^(1) x 3 x10^(-20),
which is equal to 20 x
10^(-19), or 2 x 10^(-18).
In units of 1 over seconds.
So, 1/H,
we know now,
in seconds, is equal to 1 / (2
x 10^(-18) seconds).
That's (1/2) x 10^(18) or 5 x
10^(17) seconds.
One year is equal to 3 x 10^(7)
seconds.
So, the age of the Universe in
years is (5 x 10^(17)) / (3 x
10^(7)),
which is something like 1.7 x
10^(10), or 17 billion years.
So, that's the answer.
The Universe is 17 billion
years old.
It's not quite the answer
because of that assumption,
right?
The assumption was that the
Universe is expanding at the
same rate all the time,
and that's not necessarily
true.
And the next thing we're going
to do is ask the question,
"What happens if the expansion
rate of the Universe changes
with time?"
It probably does.
It almost certainly does,
because the Universe is filled
with mass.
What does mass do?
Mass exerts--well,
Newton would have it that mass
exerts gravitational force.
It slows down the expansion of
the Universe.
So, what do you expect?
You expect the Universe to be
slowing down gradually.
And this gives rise to a couple
of possibilities,
and I think I mentioned this
briefly in passing.
Now, we're going to do a
more--in more detail.
This is the scale factor of the
Universe, which started at 0.
Here's time.
Here's now.
Here's whatever the scale
factor of the Universe is now,
and what has happened.
Here's what it looks like if
there's no change.
So, this is constant expansion.
And so, it is this amount of
time that turns out to be 17
billion years.
But in fact,
it seems likely that the
Universe is, in fact,
slowing down.
So, what does that look like?
Well, that means that in the
future it's going to do this.
That means that in the past,
it was doing this,
because it's presumably been
slowing down since the very
beginning.
And that means that the
Universe started later than you
think, because it started
expanding more quickly than it
is now,
and then it's been slowing down.
So, in fact,
you might say that what we've
really shown is that the
Universe has to be less than 17
billion years old.
By the way, this calculation is
why it was such bad news when
Hubble got the answer wrong.
You will recall from the
problem set, Hubble thought that
the Hubble Constant was 500
kilometers per second per
megaparsec.
500 is a bigger number.
It means--it's what?
Seven times bigger than we
currently believe.
That means that Hubble's
estimate of the age of the
Universe was a factor of 7
smaller than 17 billion years,
which is about 2.5 billion
years.
So, the implication of Hubble's
result in the Big Bang context,
at least, was that the Universe
was 2.5 billion years old.
That was very bad news,
because the geologists had
already figured that the Earth
was 4 billion years old.
And it's not good news to have
a planet that's a factor of two
older than the Universe.
And so, this was part of the
initial suspicion of the Big
Bang explanation.
Part of the reason people tried
to develop "steady state" ideas
was that Hubble's calculation of
the constant gave you an age of
the Universe that was in
contradiction to existing
geological ages measured on
Earth.
By now, we're up to 17 billion
years and that seems to--that's
fine.
The Earth is only 4.5 billion
years old, so there's no
conflict there anymore.
There are some star clusters
that are known to be 12 or 13
billion years old,
and they caused some trouble
for some values of the Hubble
Constant until quite recently.
Okay.
But then, this begs a question;
namely, "What's going to happen
in the future?"
Could it be that the expansion
of the Universe stops,
turns around,
and comes back,
leading to a "big crunch,"
another one of these technical
terms?
And how much mass would the
Universe have to contain for
that to be true?
So, let me do that calculation
now.
This is something we know how
to do.
This is an escape velocity
problem.
You know, you throw a pen up in
the air.
If you throw it slowly,
it stops, turns around,
and comes back.
If you throw it fast,
it goes away.
Or, to put it a different way,
if you throw a pen up in the
air at some velocity,
whether it comes back or not
depends on the gravitational
force of the planet you're
standing on,
which, in turn,
depends on the mass and the
density of that planet.
So, if you set your Universe
into motion, it's expanding
outward.
Depending on the density of the
Universe, it can stop,
turn around,
and fall back,
or it can keep going.
So here's the calculation.
Here's us, or any other
observer.
It works no matter what you do.
Then there's some galaxy,
some distance,
D, away from us.
It's moving outwards at a rate
of some velocity,
V, where V is
related to D by this
equation--second per megaparsec,
that's right.
And then, what's trying to pull
it back?
Well, the mass inside of this
region is trying to hold it
back.
It's only the mass inside of
that region because the mass
outside of the--we talked about
this in the context of planets.
This all cancels out.
And so, what is the escape
velocity?
So, the escape velocity,
you may recall,
is the square root of what?
2 GM/D.
That's the escape velocity of
this object.
Let me make sure I haven't
screwed this up.
No, that's right.
And so, the question is,
"Is V greater than
V_escape?"
All right.
So, let's evaluate this.
What's M?
M is equal to the
density times the volume.
Density--we'll call that--give
it its usual symbol of ρ.
And the volume is 4/3 π
D^(3).
That's the volume of this
sphere of material.
And you'll see why I translated
into density in a minute.
The velocity is equal to
H times D.
So, the question is:
is H times D
greater than the square root of
2 G/D times the mass,
ρ 4/3 πD^(3)?
All right, let's square both
sides.
I've got to get rid of this
square root sign.
So H^(2)D^(2).
Is H^(2)D^(2)
greater than 2 G ρ 4/3
π?
And we've got D^(3) /
D, so that's
D^(2).
And here's the key thing:
the Ds cancel.
The distance cancels.
It doesn't matter which galaxy
you pick.
It doesn't matter how far away
that galaxy is.
You get the exact same result
for every portion of the
Universe you examine.
So, the question becomes,
"Is the density less than
3H^(2) / 8 π G?"
I've just rearranged the terms.
This is the ρ.
It's still on the less-than
side.
I've taken the-- 2 x 4 = 8,
that's this 8.
There's a π,
that goes down here.
This 3 comes over on top,
and the H^(2) stays
where it is.
So, this quantity is defined as
the critical density.
If the density of the Universe
is less than the critical
density, the Universe expands
forever.
If the density of the Universe
is greater than the critical
density, then the Universe
re-collapses.
So, we can calculate this.
This is all constants on this
right-hand side.
We've measured H,
so we know what that is.
3 x 2 x 10^(-18),
that's H.
We worked that out,
squared, over 8 π 7 x
10^(-11).
And now, it's just arithmetic.
And I'll tell you the answer.
You can work it out for
yourself.
I got 6 x 10^(-27),
and this is in units of
kilograms per meter cubed.
That's a really small density.
It doesn't take much to hold
the Universe back.
On the other hand,
the Universe is really big.
Obviously, the density of this
room, of the air in this room
is, you know,
30 orders of magnitude bigger.
That's why the Earth isn't
expanding, because we're so
dense that our little region of
the Universe has turned around
and re-collapsed long since.
But if you take the Universe,
as a whole, planets are rare.
Stars are rare.
Galaxies, even, are rare.
And it turns out,
as we'll discuss next time,
that the Universe is actually
fairly close in bulk.
If you take a large enough
region that includes all the
empty space, it turns out that
the average density of the
Universe is actually
surprisingly close to this
critical value at which the
Universe will be balanced
between expanding forever and
re-collapsing.
And so, we'll talk about how
you actually measure the average
density of the Universe,
and thus, determine the fate of
the Universe,
next time.